hi I'm Angela with wired and I'm here
with studying from Kim's gate our tree
and we are here at Golden Gate Park in
San Francisco and Tony is going to teach
me how to shoot a bow and arrow
okay these are called Fitness Li and
these are finger tap is to protect you
and makes it more relaxing and help you
with your release okay then what is this
thing on my arm this is an armed guard
is to protect your arm from getting hit
by the string so that's what protection
so if I just want to get into archery
sort of at a basic level like what are
the steps I need to go through like what
are the main things that I need to work
so the first thing that we want to go
through is the anatomy what a bow this
is a stabilizer this is a bow sight and
this is an arrow rest and right here we
have what we call the knot locator
now for shooting-wise the form first
thing that we talk about is the stance
like this with a toe tip lining up
straight down at the shooting light okay
so now what I need you to do is to bring
this bring this arm over here and now
that way and your body supposed to be
straight up see how solid you are right
now yeah yeah you don't really need a
lot of muscles now I lost shooting yeah
exactly
so first the arrow has three flashing
and you want to make sure that the odd
color fletching faces you so it's ready
to be shot
so now that we know the basics how do
you become a master Archer it's actually
at the beginning most of the people will
be using their arm and shoulder the pool
so you'll be seeing them having released
like this instead of having a release
for the back okay
and as you release your follow-through
should be looking like this okay how
long do people train before they're
ready for something like the Olympics or
the world
Wow the shortest amount of time dyno up
is two years and the longest amount of
time probably forever all right yeah
because you can there's no age limit for
the Olympics the archery I mean I said
there are people say in the 50s they
were shooting